Let's talk about space
and history being made on the launch pad.
“3 ... 2 ... 1 ....”
"America has launched."
For the first time ever
a private company, SpaceX
has put people into orbit.
Launching a new capsule, a new rocket
it's a major, major thing.
It’s all about building a commercial space industry.
Going back to the Moon.
We should become a multi-planet civilisation.
Even if it’s just a science base.
Going to Mars.
And back here on Earth
hypersonic flights at speeds
that’ll make the Concorde look like a Cessna.
look like a Cessna.
But what makes this launch special?
Why is all this money being spent on space?
And do we really need to fly New York to Shanghai
in 39 minutes?
Billionaires dream big.
And that’s Elon Musk to a T.
And he wants us to dream big too.
There are many troubles in the world.
These are important and we need to solve them.
But we also need things that make us excited to be alive.
Everything is a stepping stone to the next step
to the next technological feat.
So let's understand: Elon Musk's goal
is to build, by 2050, a city on Mars that will have
a population of a million people.
Pretty amazing considering that not long ago
about the only things flying were hot air balloons
and gliders made of wood.
But that changed in 1903 with the Wright brothers.
Orville and Wilbur flew the first motorised plane.
And after that — well, things took off.
The F 13 was the first all-metal commercial plane.
It carried four passengers.
The ’40s saw the rise of the Constellation
and the fall of speed records.
Then came the Comet.
The world's first commercial jet airliner.
It crashed a few times because of stress fractures
around its square windows.
It’s why windows on planes today are oval.
The ’70s brought the supersonic Concorde.
In the early 2000s the Airbus A380 and 787 Dreamliner
made it cheaper for airlines to fly people around.
And today there’s Elon Musk and his plans for the Starship
to fly us to other planets — or even between cities
at insane speeds.
The critical breakthrough that’s needed
for us to become a
spacefaring civilisation
is to make space travel like air travel.
We’ll talk about
intercity commutes
on rockets a little later.
But let’s talk about this SpaceX launch first.
“Lift-off!”
Up until now only governments
in the US, Russia and China have been able
to fly people into space.
So this is the first commercial company
to take people into low-Earth orbit.
And this is a test mission called Demo-2.
It’s also — as NASA likes to remind us
the first launch of American astronauts
from American soil
in almost a decade.
Astronauts Bob Behnken
and Doug Hurley
rode up in a capsule
called the Crew Dragon.
It’s like a big SUV that seats up to seven.
But it’s less tin can Apollo 11, more sleek modern kitchen
with touchscreens.
Bad weather delayed the launch by a few days.
“Unfortunately we are not going to launch today.”
But then there was lift-off ...
Lift-off! Go NASA, go SpaceX, godspeed Bob and Doug!
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
to the International Space Station, or the ISS
where Behnken and Hurley will stay up to four months.
We’re given the honour
to name this capsule.
Without further ado
we would like to
welcome you aboard
capsule Endeavour.
It’s historic. And sure, it’s something to celebrate.
But what’s in it for SpaceX? And NASA?
Well privatised space flight means the US
doesn’t have to spend as many tax dollars
to transport cargo and people to the ISS.
Since NASA retired the Space Shuttle in 2011
We sure hope that everybody was able to take
just a little part of the journey with us.
it’s had to rely on Russian Soyuz rockets
to get to the space station.
It costs roughly $85 million a seat
to send a NASA astronaut up on the Soyuz.
SpaceX is going to charge about $55 million per seat.
NASA also saves money by getting private companies
like SpaceX and Boeing to compete for contracts.
They take on the big expenses of innovation and testing
and it drives down the costs for NASA.
This rocket, you know — nuts to bolts, top to tail
all of it is owned by a commercial entity.
Not one part of it is owned by NASA or the US government
except for, well,
the astronauts
and the patches on their chest.
Musk started his company with $100 million
of his own cash. That was 18 years ago.
Today his private company is reportedly worth
as much as $36 billion.
So what does that tell you?
There’s money to be made in space.
In 2018 hundreds of billions of dollars were spent
on things like satellite-based entertainment
mapping and weather.
In 20 years people think space-related goods
and services could be worth more than a trillion.
That trillion-dollar figure includes projects like
a new satellite-based internet, space tourism and mining
on mineral-rich asteroids and on the Moon.
What becomes more valuable than gold is water.
And water has been discovered on the Moon.
And that's what everyone is trying to race to, to get at.
And it’s not just about water to drink.
People are looking at the Moon as a potential
gas station on the way to Mars.
Because when you split water into oxygen and hydrogen
and liquify it you get rocket fuel.
And the US isn’t the only country
with plans for the Moon.
Russia’s going. China and India are too.
The thing is, is that whoever really gets there first
really gets to decide the rules.
So there are plenty of business incentives.
And companies like SpaceX and Boeing
well, they want to be the airlines to space.
But first they have to show they can do it safely.
And to do that they’ve had to learn
from some spectacular failures.
"And we appear to have had a launch vehicle failure."
If you’re going to have a problem with engines
it's better to have it on the ground.
“Oooh! Oh no!”
As anyone in space will tell you
all failures — while really, really awful
as long as they don't kill anybody
they're incredible learning experiences.
Boeing, which is a SpaceX competitor
is still learning too.
It’s developing its own spacecraft
for astronauts called the Starliner.
But it’s had its problems.
"And lift-off. The rise of Starliner — a new era of human space flight."
Last December a test flight without a crew got lost
on the way to the space station because of
a software glitch.
Boeing is going to be back — pretty sure of that.
But how soon is anybody's guess.
For SpaceX it’s not just about getting to space.
Because on top of everything else Elon Musk also wants
to rocket civilians between cities in no time at all.
A commercial flight from New York to Shanghai
in 39 minutes.
“Anywhere on Earth in under an hour”
that’s their sales pitch.
So far there’s no timetable for this adventure.
It may never even happen.
But people are already asking questions
like: Imagine your carbon footprint on one of those flights?
Not to mention the jetlag.
I think it will be just a white elephant in the end.
Why do we need to fly like that?
We have to apply our technology
for the benefit of humanity.
Who knows? Humanity might benefit in the end.
But right now there are some powerful commercial drivers
that have some people saying:
Let’s keep an eye on this space race.
I can see a future of an enormous amount of countries
private enterprises that go into space.
Space tourism. Hotels on the Moon.
Exploitation of the
Moon for minerals.
“We have a lift-off!”
You have to remember that the first plaque that was
left on the Moon — it's still there — by the Apollo 11 said:
“We Came in Peace for all Mankind.”
And that has to continue.
There’s a famous picture of Earth called the Pale Blue Dot.
It was taken 30 years ago by a space probe called Voyager 1
6 billion kilometres away.
In it the Earth is about the size of a pixel
you can barely see us.
But it was enough to inspire Carl Sagan, the cosmologist.
For him that picture
“underscores our responsibility to deal
more kindly with one another, and to preserve and cherish
the pale blue dot — the only home we've ever known.”
If anything those words mean more today
than they ever did.
If there’s a story or a topic in the news you want us to
to unpick and explain, leave a comment
wherever you’re watching this video.
And make sure to follow, like or subscribe to Al Jazeera
so you won’t miss our next episode.
I'll see you next week.